[Musica]
il catena delle nuove là degli anni
ottanta starò bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuto che sono video sono felice
oggi siamo su venerdì 13 venduto tra
uscisse anche perché ormai io gioco da
qualsiasi horror esistente nel mondo e
questo mi sembra uno dei più decenti
anche se effettivamente il nono aveva
l'idea di come giocare quindi autoplay e
vediamo se sei jason il tuo obiettivo è
quello di uscire tutti gli altri nella
mappa va bene se non degli altri
devi sopravvivere in tutti i modi
necessari
ci sono molti modi per scappare
sopravvivere fino alla fine guidare la
macchina fino all'uscita a chiamare la
polizia
corre l'incontro finché non arrivano o
provare a battere jason attaccandolo se
se hai le palle bene per tutto il resto
non ho voglia di leggerlo perché sono
pigro quindi andiamo su wii play ma solo
online sta roba
poi faccio pagare 9 giocata roma del
genere anni uno già uno che si chiama
hannibal come il giocatore non metterlo
tranquillità e sapete ragazzi non ho la
più pallida idea dichiarò bassi ace ma
neanche lontanamente credo che sia più
che altro un
[Musica]
1984 è la madonna a che figata
così a caso senza il motivo va bene ciao
jazz incassato ha preso un 4 a scuola in
matematica
io c'ho già il bel culo cinque minuti
dopo sopravvivi ma che [ __ ] foster
wallace
no no no ecco già è sbagliato sembrava
la scena horror con lo stretto sugli
occhi ma ragazzi non solo si sopravvive
non posso nascondermi negli armadi
la pentola pentola bastardo fossero nel
cassetto non c'è niente che sanno fare
nell'esodo letto credo che sia entrato
ragazzi a possono tenere respiro che
figata
la compressione già andato poiché sfiga
ma sono riuscito a [ __ ] un giocatore
online ma quindi jason è comandato da
uno online in questo momento quindi è
entrato ed uscito bravo deficiente era
perché io c'ho il bel culo sono la [ __ ]
non voglio subito all'inizio dei film
horror muoiono tutti neri
chi è nero non è per essere razzisti è
proprio così ma mi conviene scappare
cosa faccio io non ho capito dove è
andato c'erano per far vedere quanto
detto sopra quanto tempo per
sopravvivere che non ho capito già
chiazze solito gioco rega madonna che
culo tondo che ciò chiamatelo sosta
mappa ragazze un'ora che corrono ad ora
voi fa trovarci tutto impossibile sì
però testa di culo non ti allontanati
sono scaricato in mano che effetti sotto
ma basta sono due addirittura ragazzi è
arrivata la [ __ ] è arrivata la [ __ ] che
fa sempre comodo rimini aprite la
finestra
sono pagato forte invece non i miei
compagni mi aprite toc toc ragazzi porca
vacca li porta
open questi come la cia ti sto gioco
open please open this cristo riporta la
donna che palle
dalla finestra testa e ai ohio tua madre
fammi entrare
cosa è successo jury chechi
fiori più di coda del morire io sto
dentro è un coltello un coltello
io stesso dentro che dite se sto dentro
io mi piace come idea me ma qualcuno è
morto a uno è morto che era quello che
stava fuori tra l'altro perfetto quindi
portaccio lo zio fester garri funzionato
aiaf
non vedo niente
ma dov'è ma non è dentro scappa scappa
scappa scappa da porta serafini
straniere cori torina cielo porca [ __ ]
che kakà non posso guardarmi indietro no
non ricordare non guarda dietro volta
terrore da dietro non ho capito se
fossero d'emilio me ne sbatto il che è
ma pensa miss a lorca [ __ ] bye bye
bye bye bye rivati veloce perché ho
sempre la resistenza di fornitori nco
morto perché è vabbè salve break free
arca vacca no no ai a chi sa che mi ha
fatto male pure il mio braccio quello e
l'altro mio braccio secondo lei subito
melo censura youtube credo erano sono
sono sicuro zio pontile incrostato che
cambia assurda posso vedere gli altri se
paghi c'è mica c'è will smith che non è
morto per primo che saranno da a una
trafigga va bene dai proviamoci un'altra
volta posso sempre con la [ __ ] somma ci
mancherebbe altro se facciamo così
ragazzi adesso seguo loro prendo questo
seguo loro bravo chiudi vuoi farne
presenze è che il marpione
dove nascondersi io mi nascondo braccia
o porca [ __ ] li ha privati sesso jean
dagli altri sei sono già andati ci ha
messo un secondo mi sa che rimanere in
casa non è stata proprio una grandi la
cia ha ragione gli altri ragazzi
[Musica]
no
bene ho trovato finalmente un gioco in
cui sono capace normale terza telai
proviamo che non mi fate fare centro una
volta li mortacci vostri sono mica io
gen no non sono andate a cagare
stavolta sono deciso a vincere mi sono
rotto il cazzo cioè lo dico ciao zio ma
quasta ripara la macchina sta facciamo
così diamo darle una mano stato al
massimo serov ecco la polizia sta
arrivando in cinque minuti si dovrà
esistere cinque minuti ragazzi è il play
parolacce veloce sia veloce cutie yuri
semin stare insieme più di fiori
no ma io che sono un [ __ ] io cazzola
questa vado mai ancora la macchina vi
metterà maria la fuga arriva a pula tra
quattro minuti che sommati a posto la
macchina arkham amiche abbiamo sentito
la macchina fuori dal finestrino
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
sia grazie
scappa scappa vai bicchia mica sono io
l'uomo era già stata lei la macchina
investimenti in vesti investi indietro
guida donna acquista batte scarsa vena
di elettro marcia retromarcia veloce
veloce zia mica quanto devono rimanere
in casa 4 fatto la cazzata del secolo
tutto il retro si sta facevano poi
investirlo scusa
una ragazza cio l'ansia mi come calcio
ha fatto sia devi farti tutta la mappa
in retro spiegami esatto trovando
davanti
mica la curva in retro si fa scema
questa non che io dubiti delle sue
capacità d'acquisto
se resisti due minuti e mezzo così a in
retromarcia abbiamo vinto cosa molto
difficile però non ha visto continua
teletrasportarsi lo zio vai vai vai vai
parti fatti ma no non ci credo non
sapevo che non saper guidare e cazzi
tuoi che vai vai da neve lo sapevo come
sapeva guidare questo non perché una
donna è perché non c'è mai pregiudizi
solo che guido meglio io si sa perché ha
fatto due minuti ma anche dai non posso
perdere gravi rendete conto di quello
che appena successo
9 che fosse più o meno mi rende sai
corner è una cosa che fanno i bambini
ok fanno i bambini corrono va bene dormi
una mano a sopravvivere entrano dentro
peraltro normale nelle cose per mi
lancio di spalla ora ti chiudi tanto la
polizia arriva tra un minuto sono
entrati in una casa piena di haters
porca eva 10 secondi ho vinto in teoria
poi non so grandi laghi come che la
partita non finisce dove amica stasta
polizia ha quindi la devo raggiungere
pure ma la procura
dovere palle raga non so dove la prima
idea di dove sia polizia zio e zia
scostamento zio kakà mi esce da lì c'è
la cia puglia vieni vieni via vieni via
kabul a kabul a seguire brava doveva fu
la trova la tu che ci avrei giocato
sicuramente più divento gioco minchia
questo qua madonna non sculettare se
stai per morire porca eva non sei una
sfilata di dolce gabbana ma non c'è la
sirena da noi non lo farò magari gara
cioè ma va via non ci voglio credere
[Musica]
la sorella morta per strada c'era gara
vi rendete conto cosa non c'è parola
brava testa di mika questa scritta brava
complimenti che guarda pure mentre mi
ammazzano non tentare di distrarlo è che
quanto ti auguro la morte porca ai quali
non perdere sono morti tutti tranne
questa cioè che rendete conto
per ultimo sopravvissuto perché a me
l'avesse fatto si sta facendo come sta
andando la pasta in pieno io rimango qua
a vedere cosa fa
ah eccolo
620 lo spray vitigni adorante sulle
ferite si sta leggermente cagando sotto
a posto ma magari se correvi in attivo
prima come non lo so io perché si
affermo questo non come queste scemare
come si celi il problema te lo meriti
anche un pochettino in realtà è che lo
meriti abbastanza in tutto questo
ragazzi posso farvi una domanda ma la
polizia
[Musica]
finché hai fatto fuori campo 08 questo
ragazzi la polizia stava mangiando delle
ciambelle al caramello dal bar di fianco
non so non capisco dove minchia era la
polizia e tutto questo
[Risate]
macché che ha meno meno male che non ho
capito come è finita però va bene quale
ragazzi sono bravo anche in questi
giorni fa piacere un sacco allora datevi
dei consigli stoke e un sacco di voi
sapranno come giocare a salva
sicuramente ci farà una territori perché
bellissimo l'unico problema è che ma
porca fatemi sapere ragazzi se volete
altro episodio se non volete fatemi
sapere come minchia si gioca sta roba
ricordatevi che non è vero che muore per
ultimo negli horror ma equa vj come
senza il primo momento mi piace anche
vari social che come di tornare al
tiziana sensi di schietta e ci mettiamo
possiamo video bello ragazzi
[Musica]